you
it could be okay so thanks very much
Pete it's a pleasure to open the first
date ang conf as Pete said we have a
fantastic community in New York City and
some of the things I'm going to
illustrate the fact that one of the ways
that you really win is by bringing data
science and data engineering together
I'm going to talk about some of the
things I do in the data science group at
the New York Times but just to emphasize
we couldn't do any of that without good
data engineering so as promised I'm
Chris Wiggins I split my time between
Columbia and the New York Times and I'm
going to be talking about data science
at the New York Times data science
you've probably heard about data science
that sort of exploded in people's
consciousness in the last couple of
years this is just a track of Google
searches starting around 2013 or so
suddenly there seems to be a lot of
interest in data science and it seems to
have captivated a lot of people's hopes
and curiosities and part of that of
course is related to the fact that jobs
in data science themselves are rapidly
increasing you can go to and go to
indeed.com someday and go to the trends
section at the bottom and go look at
trends for data science and you can see
or go look for trends for anything
you're interested in you can see what
technologies and what sort of areas are
on the rise or sometimes on the decline
just kind of interesting to see and
because it's new it means many different
things to many different people so I'm
going to start by saying what data
science means to us we take a very old
classical view of data science dating
from five long years ago this is a graph
many of you how many people have seen
this graph okay good so a lot of you
have sort of been inculcated and this
particular way of thinking about data
science then there's a graph from Drew
Conway who's a New York City data
scientist and founder now founder it was
and this was drawn back when he was
merely a graduate student illustrating
one way of thinking about data science
as the intersection of machine learning
which is a you know a decade's old
academic field combining statistics and
computer science and applying machine
learning to some particular domain of
expertise so I'll talk about a few areas
where
we've seen waves of reframing questions
from a domain as machine learning tasks
and the skill set of being able to know
machine learning well enough to know
which is the right tool for the right
job to listen to a human being which is
difficult to listen to human beings and
try to figure out how to reframe their
problems as machine learning tasks to
execute the machine learning and then to
translate what you've learned in a way
that's actionable to people is what
people generally call data science yeah
and just to clarify when drew writes
hacking skills here he means not in the
post 1983 wargames definition of hacking
like breaking into stuff he means it in
the classical definition from the 50s
meaning creative solutions to a
technological problem and that is the
kind of thing that you need to do good
so this is a definition also from around
2009 if you haven't ever checked this
out Jeff Henry Becker who started the
data science group at Facebook after he
left Facebook and had some time on his
hands I guess he was just starting
cloudera around that time it's anybody
from cloud era here good ok so I don't
have to say anything I guess I'm on
video okay so Claire's awesome so Jeff
when he was starting up Clara wrote this
book beautiful data which is a
collection of essays one of the essays
is from him about the rise of the data
scientist and he says at Facebook we
felt like that traditional titles we
were using business analysts
statistician engineer research
scientists didn't quite capture what we
were wanting for our team you know
people in this group could be writing in
Python or R and trying to do hypothesis
testing regression analysis implementing
an experiment or or implementing an
algorithm of writing a product in Hadoop
which in 2009
you know was sort of innovative and most
of all communicating the results our
analyses to other organizations members
of the organization and a clear and
concise fact fashion to capture the
skill set required for this we created
the role of data scientist and that
resonates with what we tend to think
about is the sort of unicorn like aspect
of being a data scientist that you want
these people to be solving problems that
are relevant to the whole company and
therefore you want them to have
visibility into and awareness of what
are the real problems for the company so
you can't do that if you're going to
have a group that's in the basement you
need these people to be communicating
with everyone in the company
and solving problems that are relevant
also our rocks and being a statistician
rocks but you know if you really want to
contribute to a company and the company
you like if once you accept that
software is eating everything and you
accept that software pretty much has
eaten everything you know that like
contributing to the company by making an
interesting insight if it's just a deck
is good but if you really want to be
useful to the company at some point you
have to implement and deploy at least
push to dev right and better work with
people who can for yourself push to prod
you really want to be pushing the
product with with with the work which is
what we try to do in the data science
group with the New York Times so with
that by way of background let me also
say something about my own background my
own background which has shaped a lot of
the way I think about data science comes
from trying to get this done in biology
so biology is a field which I think is
full of really interesting case studies
for pain and data pain and the problem
where you think you understand a complex
system you've been working on it for 100
years and then suddenly you find
yourself a wash and data so it's not
necessarily a cutting-edge field for all
of data engineering although we from
cloud era is going to be talking about
ways of putting spark to work to solve
problems in biology but it is a field
where you have a community of people who
have been studying some system for a
while it's really complex they have
their own sort of understandings of it
and then they suddenly find themselves
awash with you know an astronomical
abundance of data although astronomical
by biological standards is not the same
as astronomical by you know internet
standards but it was a lot of data so as
one good case study of this I mean it it
happened to me when I was in graduate
school so it had a big impact on me
because I was I was young at the time so
as a good example of how biology had a
transformation and had sort of a data
moment when I started graduate school in
1993 you know the relationship between
quantitative modeling of complex things
and biology was was pretty tenuous there
wasn't a lot of work by you know
computational people in biology that was
really impacting the field of biology
and right in the middle of my PhD
this happened on the right so just so I
know if anybody's coming from a science
background does anybody know what this
is a picture of on the right good it's a
genome and in particular it's the genome
of homophily influenza and in particular
it's the genome of the first living
critter to have its whole genome
sequenced so I can remember when I was
sitting at lunch with some other
graduate students and one of them came
in holding science magazine in June of
1995 and this was the cover image and we
were all like okay this is just gonna
change everything because once you have
the whole genome of some critter then
you can sequence even bigger critters so
once you once you can sequence this bug
then it was clear that you could
sequence yeast flies worms humans then
you can sequence multiple humans and
then the whole like the whole game has
changed because instead of trying to
study some complex system like we did on
the left where you put it in a petri
dish and you pour some really bad drugs
on it and maybe it turns blue or maybe
it doesn't turn blue we have just
abundant data about this critter and
then we need to figure out okay well how
do we represent those data in a way
that's useful to people I contend that
the pain that the biology felt is a lot
like the pain where you've been studying
things by like interviewing a focus
group of 20 people at a time and you ask
them a couple of questions and you think
you understand and then suddenly you
have tremendous abundance of web logs
and you actually know how they actually
use the product and what they actually
do and then you have to figure out okay
how do we represent them how do we
answer questions that are of interest to
the domain experts which might be people
in marketing a product finance right in
the same way that we had to turn
questions from biologists into machine
learning questions in biology in the 90s
so I thought it was a very useful in
retrospect I think it was a very useful
place to learn the sort of pain of data
which we now call data science and then
the main thing that I think we learned
from that was that the biggest problem
is getting a new mindset like having a
new tool set like how do right that's
good but having a new mindset like oh
maybe we can give data a seat at the
table for trying to answer these
difficult questions that actually is
much more useful and and necessary right
the new tool said is necessary do but
it's not sufficient right you really
need people who are like okay let us
take data seriously and think hard about
how we're going to use data to drive
difficult decisions which brings us to
the New York Times
so the New York Times is not a recent
company and it's not by birth a
technology company right this is old
company this is the first image of the
New York Times from 1851 when it was the
New York Daily Times and it was merely
in newspaper that is the only way of
getting information to people was in the
form of a dead tree and when you gave
them that dead tree they gave you back
nothing you learned nothing about the
way they interacted with the product and
that was the way that was the soul of
the interaction between the New York
Times and its users for the first you
know 88% of its existence right dead
tree how on earth are you going to put
data science into a company like this
well to make it more clear let me say a
little bit about the org chart of the
New York Times here is the org chart of
the New York Times and in fact here's
the lorry chart of most traditional
media companies church is the people who
keep the craft of journalism right they
keep and defend the craft of journalism
and they think about that craft state is
everything else right sometimes called
the business side and I sit solidly in
state so I want to make clear how how
that relates to things that you may know
sometimes when I tell people oh I'm a
data scientist at the New York Times
they say awesome I love the upshot you
guys do really good work in data science
I said no those people are awesome
they're great I love the upshot props
but I'm not in that group those people
are Church they're sweet the you know
the grade they distribute their code on
github
it's very technically fleeting but I
just want to make sure that you know
that's not what I'm talking about
or sometimes when I say I do data
science at the New York Times people say
oh I love the interactive graphics that
your team produces and I say yes those
people are awesome and I'm not with
those people those people are Church
they're great but I'm not I'm not
solving those problems and in particular
the particular part of state that I sit
in is engineering so you may not think
of engineering as a central part of
media companies and again for a place
like the New York Times that's pretty
fair for the first 88% of its age but I
do sit in engineering and in particular
I sit in a group called data science and
engineering so there's a group in the
soft in the larger engineering
Enterprise called data science and
engineering which brings these skills
together
the data engineers who are trying to
capture curate make useful and
actionable all of the data that the
company generates and although it's only
you know a little over 3,000 people we
have many different functions going on
in a company right after 164 years you
build a lot of diverse muscles and all
those muscles generate interesting data
sets and the data science team that puts
that is trying to learn from those data
those may sound like different functions
and I feel like Society has sort of
talked about data science and data
engineering are different things but I
want to show you that they're intimately
related Josh Willis put it in words
about a month ago and in a way that I
really resonated with Joshua recently
left cloud era he said what a data
scientist talk about when they get
together for lunch how hard it is to
hire data engineers it's true
none of the stuff that I can talk about
I could do if there weren't good data
engineers at the New York Times who had
made the data useful right who had
thought really hard about how are we
going to capture the data how are going
to make these data useful right and the
people on my team have to work well with
the data engineers so and our group like
we're in the same place in the org chart
we sit next to each other when
something's pathological we walk over to
the other cubicle and ask why is this
data pathology there and nobody knows
the pathologies in your data better than
the data engineers so it's very useful
to work closely with them now I did
haven't really answered why you have an
engineering team the reason that a media
company has an engineering team is an
unattended unintended consequence of the
world wide web so here just like on the
Left which is the first-ever edition of
the dead tree New York Times on the
right is the birth of the New York Times
as a website so on my birthday in 1996
the New York Times introduced a website
and they reported on it with the quaint
headline the New York Times introduces a
website which sort of the style of the
time and what has that has led to is an
abundance of data right so today
millions of people go to the website
every day and millions more interact
with the digital content via mobile
devices of one form or another right so
unlike for the first 80 80 % of the
company's existence where the made the
method of conveyance was dead tree now
the method of conveyance is digital now
the exciting thing about digital when
people put up websites they're like ooh
this cool this is going to be like some
new way of communicating with people
that's not what's cool
cool about digital is the fact that you
know like with the radio radio sits
there and it receives photons and it
amplifies those photons and plays it in
your ear but the radio station doesn't
find out what you listen to
right they have no knowledge about what
you listening to broadcast TV same thing
digital on the other hand is a
communication right every time you point
click scroll on mouse-over
right you are making a request right and
that request is received by website
which if that website so chooses can log
it right and can learn at scale what
people actually feel about your product
this is not violating any corporate
secrets you can open up Google are you
gonna open up Chrome and you can go to
the developer tools you can go to the
network tools visit any website you can
see what information are you sharing
with any website right so you know some
random website I went to a couple of
years ago about the sports and you know
here's here's what my browser was
telling the New York Times write a bunch
of cookie information where I came from
how many characters I had read right and
unless you think that the New York Times
is the most technologically advanced
company in the world I'm sure you're
giving up at least as much information
when you go to you know Google or
Facebook and don't even think about how
much information you're giving up on
your mobile phone right I mean like the
reason Google now can tell you like how
many people are at this coffee shop at
every hour of the day is because they're
tracking like where you are all the time
all day so enjoy that and all of these
interactions with the world are
generating an abundance of data this is
a great quote about data exhausts the
quote is social activities generate
large quantities of potentially valuable
data data were not generated for the
purpose of learning however the
potential for learning is great any
guesses what year this was written you
haven't had enough coffee yet written in
1993 by John Chambers anybody heard of
John Chambers ok so John Chambers
invented s which became our right so I
put this in in part to say that there
actually is like a literature out there
that we can draw on of people in this
case from Bell Labs thinking for years
about what are you going to do with
abundance of data exhaust how do you go
about and learn from observational data
ad scale including digital data so
a couple people knew it right like Bell
Labs they saw it right they saw it
coming in the nineties but it took a
couple of decades more before normal
companies companies that had not yet
been eaten by software to see that the
web is not just like your online
presence which I think it's the way
people in media thought about the web in
the 90s are like okay this is gonna be
our online presence instead of going to
brick-and-mortar or buying the dreaded
dead tree you know we have some presence
on the world wide web but people now
realize that the web is like a
microscope for understanding your entire
audience at scale right if you have the
technology in place to log and if you
have the mindset in place to learn right
you can really understand your audience
at scale and you can use that to drive
for marketing decisions product
decisions business decisions moreover
people I think now realized that the web
is also an experimental tool right
because if your product is code then
it's a matter of just encoding showing
different things to different people and
learning how that affects people and
once you're doing experiments and you're
allowing experiments to drive your
decisions you're really doing an
optimization right so that's been a big
change in mindset to think about the web
not as like a place where you push
pixels around but a place where you
learn what your audience actually does
what your audience wants you can do that
if you really have the right mindset
about the value in your data right
that's why sort of like Harvard Business
Review has these blog posts about data
being the new oil right there actually
is a lot of value there but you need to
think clearly about the whole value
chain so that's all cool and fun and
intellectually interesting but the New
York Times is not like a academic place
it's not like we made a data science
group because we want to just think big
thoughts the value of a data science
group is to try to explore how the world
is changing and the graph on the right
is a good graph about how the world is
changing and I think it makes clear that
it's not just an academic exercise to
think about how to understand the
audience better let's zoom in on graph
on that so another unintended
consequence of the world wide web is an
amazing change in advertising and that's
relevant to the New York Times because
for the last 150 years or years with a
craft of journalism
been intimately connected with the
business of newspapering and in the
business model of newspapering the
income is advertising right so in the
late 90s was good times good times right
you basically could just give away the
New York Times for free because
advertising was was was paying the bills
and then something amazing happened
2004 through 2008 or so and this is not
the end of the economy and like Lehman
Brothers etc etc before that there was a
big change where advertisers rethink a
classic line in advertising so there's
this classic line in advertising
the problem with advertising is I waste
half my money but I don't know which
half right so once you have the digital
and you actually contract the way people
interact then you know which half and so
advertisers started rethinking where
they were going to split their put their
advertising spend to zoom in on that
every publisher is now challenged we're
trying to think about what is going to
be the business model of journalism for
the next century and at this point in
our species you know we don't we don't
really know like we're still in search
of a sustainable and scalable business
model so it's not just an academic
exercise to learn from the data by the
way just to zoom in on where the money
went you can keep track of advertising
revenue and Google Facebook magazines
newspapers and you can see this amazing
trend where advertisers just sort of
move away from newspapers and move
towards the Google so the New York Times
takes this takes this seriously right
this is a this is a existential
challenge to the business of newspaper
in which again is intimately connected
with the craft of journalism and the New
York Times has taken a very hard look at
that if you want to read a great
document about innovation in general but
also around media and publishing there's
this excellent document which is usually
just called the innovation report about
96 pages was leaked to BuzzFeed which is
how we as a species all now have a copy
of it on the interwebs but it's a great
document about the ways that a legacy
organization in particular faces the
challenge of innovation and what are the
what are the challenges in process that
keep keep an organization from becoming
a tech company one of the
recommendations in the innovation report
is that there should be more engineering
and everything that there's a role for
software and for software engineering in
church and in state and that's one of
the things we're
trying to do broadly so broadly put the
goal of the data science group is to
solve problems in newsroom and business
throughout the company try to liberate
and learn from the data we have try to
solve using machine learning and
predictive and prescriptive tools
business and newsroom problems that are
facing the company right and that means
interacting well with people throughout
the company so what have we learned I
tend to think about because I come from
a machine learning background like my
research in my published research at
Columbia is all about using machine
learning to answer questions in biology
with biologists I tend to think about
the work in the group as broken up in
different types of machine learning and
usually I think about that in terms of
are you doing unsupervised learning
supervised learning or reinforcement
learning or roughly in words that I can
use with non technologists are you
looking for descriptive analyses
prescriptive analysis or predictive
analysis and I'll show you examples of
things that we do and framing it that
way I think helps people think about how
is this work that you're doing and
integrate into my process and if you'd
like to know more there's a class that I
taught about thought on this with a coat
on it with Jake Hoffman and the spring
called modeling social data so an
example of a predictive analysis so one
thing you might want to do that's
predictive is you might want to look at
all your users and say can I predict
which users are going to go from a
non-reader
or repeat reader to a subscriber right
so that's something that you want to
predict and you might like Michael you
might like to learn a model that takes
in as input a data set in which every
row was an individual all the columns
are everything you can think about that
person right and that takes that's an
act of creative computational social
science it's an act where you work
closely with people from different parts
of the company and then there's one
sacred column the column that's like did
they cancel their subscription and
that's really the goal is to predict
that column from all the other columns
that's a classic machine learning task
but it's reframed in a way that speaks
to people who fear people cancelling
their subscription right so you can sort
of explain to the rest of the company
here's the thing that we want our users
to do or not to do let's reframe that as
a prediction problem and learn what we
can learn about their behaviors of
course you don't just want to predict
who's going to become a subscriber you
also
want to predict which of your loyalists
are suddenly going to cancel and to do
that in a way that's useful to the
company you want not only to solve the
engineering challenge of finding the
at-risk people but the science challenge
of figuring out what are the risky
behaviors that is you want a model
that's not only predictive but also
interpretable so that's a big challenge
to take all of the different attributes
which here I've just called super cool
stuff because I can't tell you unless
you come work with us and then to learn
some sort of significance and to say
well these are behaviors that are good
and these are behaviors that are bad and
in many ways that's a lot like the kind
of things that biologists have been
trying to do for the last ten years so
you know a paper I wrote in 2007 was
about exactly this you know you take a
bunch of genes and you get to watch them
going up and down and then you want to
predict which genes go up and down but
if you're their yeast biologist you
don't really care which genes go up and
down you want to know what are the
control knobs that make those genes go
up and down you're in this case it's
sequence elements so a lot of the way
I've reframed problems at the neuera
times is at a high level pretty much the
same thing I was trying to do in biology
trying to take things that were of
interest to the biologists reframe it in
terms of questions that they can
understand why that's an important
question and then order those hundreds
or thousands or an infinite number of
possible features by how important they
are other prediction problems at the New
York Times well unlike many modern media
companies the New York Times still makes
dead trees right so we still have a very
important print business and they're
interesting logistic optimal logistics
and optimization problems around they're
just delivering the right number of
copies to the right store you can
actually save many many data scientist
salaries if you do that right again I
can't tell you anything
business sensitive about how many
money's we're talking about here or what
particular models are trying out here
but one of the things we've done in the
last year is to build out a framework
like the infrastructure for doing
careful statistical experiments on
multiple algorithms on multiple stores
right so it's it's a very real-world
example of the kind of thing you might
do in a petri dish so that's a
prediction problem one thing that sort
of blends prediction and description is
building better recommendation engine so
it's problem well known at Spotify here
we are so at the New York Times you're
probably familiar with the
recommendation engine module or widgets
in the lower
right hand side of the homepage but
there's many many things that we can do
better if we better understand who likes
to interact with what type of content
there's a great blog post about this
that Alex Spangler who's going to give a
talk tomorrow afternoon wrote about
using collaborative topic models which
is a type of generative model for trying
to model all of the content and all the
interactions with the content at once in
order to build a better recommendation
engine just pushing that further in
terms of the ways that some of our tools
blend prediction and description Dale
Kim who's in my group also has built out
this awesome internal tool called reader
scope which takes the idea of topic
modeling even further and allows you to
interact with and try to interpret the
different types of content that are read
by people in different places of the
world or thin-sliced by different
demographic information so you can say
to an editor you know here is your like
what do people read in France well
here's the kind of things people read in
France and it's all done in Python in
flask and d3 and it gives you an
interpretable and interactive tool which
is in my experience you know you can
write a paper about machine learning and
the punchline is a loss function and a
test loss or something like that but if
you really want to work with like real
people know if you want to make
something that's interpreted CEOs or
four-star generals or whatever just
let's say people who don't know calculus
it makes a big difference if you can
just stand up a simple prototype if you
can give something that people interact
with take the machine learning model and
make it something that people can play
with it just goes miles towards helping
people feel like they understand and
their guts what you're actually doing
there's some fancy math behind that but
since I'm I don't want to spend a lot of
time on fancy math trust me there's some
generative modeling behind it which is
state of the art and allows us
essentially to model our audience
ultimately this turns into optimization
problems but it allows you to get some
insight but also Drive targeting methods
if you understand people at scale I
haven't said anything yet about
prescriptive right so describing people
is like okay I have millions of users
and 20% of them are baby boomers and 10%
of them are and this other set that sort
of gives you a description of what is or
what happened prediction is saying can I
make an accurate model that predicts say
who's going to cancel their subscription
prescriptive is when you
say to somebody among the set of actions
you are choosing here is the action I
recommend for you so an example of a
prescriptive model is this project
called blossom so last fall the New York
Times created a new unit in the newsroom
called audience development as they put
it
you know there's journalism and then
there's the art and science of making
sure that that journalism gets to as
many people as possible or as that
senior editor said we want our stuff to
be read so they created a new group that
was about how do we go about making sure
that that content is read by people and
discoverable and discovered so the
audience development team has to think
about things like how are we going to
promote our stuff on all of the social
channels right Facebook Twitter snapchat
snapchat de jour next year and the stuff
we have well you know that's hundreds of
URLs every day and there's all these
different sub accounts so if you're
somebody if you're an editor in the
audience development and principle
you're keeping in your head you know on
the order of a thousand URLs on the
order of 40 different social channels
and you're making decisions about the
way to present it and which is the right
channel every 15 minute period all day
right so that's a lot for any human
being to keep in her or his head so one
of the projects we worked on was
reframing that task as a prediction
problem like can I predict social
engagement with this story if it is
promoted or if it is not promoted and if
you can do that then you can make
prescriptive statements like I recommend
that you promote the following story on
the following channel right now so that
so on the back end what does that mean
well that means a bunch of MapReduce
that means a bunch of Python that makes
a bunch of scikit-learn that means a
bunch of you know cross-validation and
make sure that you're making something
that's statistically significant and
accurate but I can't get editors to open
up Python and interact with it on the
command line right instead editors spend
all their day in slack so we built this
very friendly slack bot called
blossom and you can interact with
blossom all the time you can ask blossom
questions like hey blossom Facebook
blossom what should I post a facebook
and and blossom will make
recommendations about what things might
be imposed in facebook blossom also has
an alert function we're in the middle of
people having a pleasant
chat among humans blossom BOTS can come
in and say hey seriously you really
should promote this story so blossom
bots will like come in and interrupt you
your process so that's an example of
prescription so prediction is like I try
to assign a score to a person that tells
you likelihood of happening prescriptive
means we've decided in advance what is
the action set and I'm going to
recommend to you what is the arc max
over the action set of some reward what
is that what is the choice that we
recommend to you now so if you think
about data science and process you sort
of think about it like this like oh I
have a bunch of data about people I'm
trying to decide on a new product or a
marketing campaign so maybe I want to
segment people and that sort of
exploration suggests to me the new
campaign or the new product and then
maybe I observe people and how they
interact with this product one should
exists and that allows me to learn how
to predict the thing I really care about
which might be a business KPI from the
things that I can observe easily which
might be you know engagement features
that you can measure right away and then
that suggests you like of the hundreds
of things that might be correlated the
subsets that seem really correlated some
of them might be causative and so you do
some sub tests
once you've done some tests then you can
do some optimization and then you have
KPIs and you just mail it in an Excel
spreadsheet to the CEO every morning
that's the way we think about like a
company and of course you know none of
that is like that right it's all
iterative right just like science right
so you do some experiments you learn
some like key leading indicators then
you see how those leading indicators
fail to do what you think they do and
new products right and you go back in
your iterate right and you're optimized
it's much more like that so how do we
get this done
you know like creating a data science
team within 164 year old company with
thousands of people takes a lot of
things coming together it's not just
about you know the choice of which which
database to use right and in fact in
some ways the things are at the bottom
so when I was last year I read a lot of
books about how to like integrate
technology and drive organizational
change one of the most useful was a book
about the US military and I got this
statement from the United States Air
Force that if you really want to get
things done in an organization you need
people ideas and things in that order so
the things are the things we usually
talk about you know
the Hadoop the method right the the the
statistical KPI say right and the ideas
are things like the change in mindset
and the idea of data science she can't
get anything done unless you've got
people who who get it and who are
willing to bless data science as a thing
so let's talk about the things like what
are the things that we deliver we try to
balance between building data prototypes
which means that we need software
engineering like we need a skill set
that includes software engineering and
the ability to at least ship to dev
right to build some prototype that
people can interact with we also want to
impact the engineering process which
means we need to be able to ship to prod
like we didn't want to build ap is that
other engineers can call on and more
broadly you know if we really want to
impact people who aren't interacting
with engineering yet you know parts of
the organization for which software has
not eaten their world we need that we're
just trying to impact their roadmaps
we're trying to give them advice that
changes their decisions about what's the
most important thing for the next
quarter prototypes well I already showed
you an example of a prototype this is a
this is a screenshot from Dale's work
before he came to the times just trying
to ingest a bunch of content and then
render in a way that's interprete
balapan different different parts of a
website or different corpora of texts
and I already showed you a prototype
that sort of manifests that printer
that's an internal data product we build
API so we deploy and puppet and we work
closely with software engineering teams
like the personalization team and as I
said impacting roadmaps is a business
term for getting people to change their
mind like people like running a company
being an operator in a company means
making and defending difficult decisions
and everyone in the company whether
you're technical or not is making
difficult decisions and we try to find
places where data can be useful for
driving those decisions like I said
before ideas are more important than
things so what are the some of the ideas
that we've been trying to promulgate one
is that data science as they say is not
done in a vacuum right so by sitting
among the data engineers it's been very
useful for getting things done for
understanding the the discrepancy
between your model of how you think the
data were generated and how the data
actually were debt generated right many
of the things that we call data munging
or data cleanup are really about the
disconnect between your model of how the
generate the data were generated and how
they
were generated so it helps to sit you
know one cubicle away from the people
who generated the data we sit alongside
a data visualization team that does a
great job building awesome d3 powered
internal data products we think a lot
about data product you know like in a
blossom example I can't make the editors
fire at Python so I have to make a
product that I can integrate into their
process I wanted to name it something
that wasn't like you know predictive
classifier for blah blah I named it
blossom right like then they know okay
that's an algorithm it's represented by
a little set of flowers I know what it
does it's not gonna like bring down the
website it's gonna be useful to me
those are product decisions multi
literacies meaning
I can't ask everybody in the company to
be functionally literate in data science
but I can try to help more and more
people be critically literate and
rhetorically literate rhetorically
literate meaning they know how to tell a
story in which data science is part of
the story and they know you know like
they know how to interpret a graph in a
way that helps them communicate to their
team or to their stakeholders or
whatever and critically literate meaning
they know when I'm lying so if I tell
them like oh I'm gonna do you know some
amazing thing with data science I want
them to be critically literate enough
that they could say no you and you're
not gonna do that that's not just not
possible it saves us all a lot of time
as a company if people understand data
science well enough to know the limits
of data science and very useful to
getting this done has been data embeds
so we try to take members of our team
and embed them in different groups so
one person is embedded in the
personalization team another in the new
markets team another is basically
embedded in marketing and one betted in
the news room and you don't like I said
before you don't want your data
scientists locked up in a basement doing
Lord knows what you want them forward
deploy like in the trenches with the
people who are going to be putting their
stuff to use it's going to make your
models better make your models more
interpretable make your product
decisions wiser get better iteration
with the cook with the customer as
effectively for internal data products
most of all though we couldn't get this
done unless we set very close to the
data engineers and so I try to have I
try to hire and build a group that
balances between sort of ipython as a
skill set and puppet and deploys deploy
as a skill set and proper data
engineering as a skill set in many ways
we are the most demanding customers for
the data
engineers and give them the hardest time
and hopefully sometimes are useful to
them ensure a new mindset is more
important than a new toolset I think
we've done that at the New York Times I
was excited about a month ago when I saw
then the CEO interviewed somewhere and
he said what's happened in the last 12
months is a growing understanding from
data science and machine learning about
how to relate the way people use the
product to subscription and retention
basically so even to have the CEO of
your company talking publicly about data
science and machine learning I think
indicates that you're a good place for
for driving or change and for
contributing to the values of the org
with data science people ideas and
things in order and the other important
thing about people is that I should say
who actually did the work so I used the
academic first person in this talk which
is every time I said I I really meant we
and every time I said we I really meant
they these are the people who actually
did all the work and those people are
coming from a variety of places so Alex
who's going to talk tomorrow is coming
from a background in CS and neuroscience
Collins coming from a background in CS
and startups dale is all but done with
his dissertation at brown and was an
astrophysicist and did two postdocs and
astrophysics Dorian's coming from a pure
math background and Nick did hard time
for seven years in AD Tech and I hope
and hopefully you've hopefully you've
met these people I encourage them all to
go to meetups in town and and learn and
to teach about what we do and I
encourage you to check out Alex's talk
tomorrow which is more about using
generative models for building a better
recommendation engine and with that I
still have a few minutes left for taking
questions thank you very much
if you were talking about the blossom
tool and if that blossom can predict say
virality of a piece of content why not
just push it into Facebook or into
Twitter so part of that is the
difference between data informed and
data-driven right it is not the case
that all of the nuances of the way that
you publish are captured in any single
scalar so any single number right so
it's far better to make suggestions to
editors than to just just put it in the
loop and have it be fully data-driven
where an algorithm just pushes directly
there are all sorts of ways in which
editors are smarter than Python and in
fact in many ways that is the the
value-add of the New York Times rate
hikes so there's all sorts of processes
that involve actually communicating with
people such that if we were to replace
them with algorithms there would be no
moat between the New York Times in any
other place right like because anybody
can build an algorithm that's gonna say
generate text right so yeah I still
think it's better for trying to I think
it's still better to think about this is
you know the way that you wouldn't want
your doctor to be replaced by you know
Robo surgeon yet I think still there's a
lot to be learned in which we can say to
the editors of all all the hundreds of
stories and all the hundreds of social
channels and all the hundreds of times a
day where you might promote this thing
here is something that seems to be a
real good idea and sometimes they follow
it sometimes they don't and in some in
many ways they're learning from it also
you know I mean this product this
project has only been live for a couple
of months so you would want to test
something out for a while before you're
just like okay
there's one question back there and I
think you had a question as well and I'm
not sure if you're moderating or I'm
moderating if I'm moderating then I
would like to hear your question please
and we'll early only spoke about the
concept of people ideas and things and
you mentioned that it came from a
military book yeah and I'd be very
interested to find out about the title
of where it came from
sure so there was an Air Force colonel
called John Boyd there's a book about
him from 2002 called Boyd the fighter
pilot who changed the art of war he was
in Korea he was active in Korea and
there's sort of a subset of military
thinking which became known as the
Reformers in the 80s which promoted a
philosophy which we would probably now
call agile but yeah yeah many things
that look like scrum basically like stop
building ridiculously large planes start
building smaller technology or tanks or
whatever start building smaller tools
that are the right tools for the right
jobs and in the latter third of the book
when he actually ends up in the Pentagon
that's where it sort of goes from
thinking about things to thinking about
people like what what are the processes
in the Pentagon which is a large
bureaucratic organization that thwart
innovation and for getting things done
Boyd
Bo yd Boyd
he's become very popular among startup
people so I actually I actually heard
about it from various thought leaders
tweeting about voidism there's another
question in the back call so thank you a
question about change management you
mentioned that you have needed to read
normal three books to change things at
new york times can you talk about your
most hardest challenge there's it's hard
to choose there's there's so many hard
challenges and and I should say that I
think that interesting ones are the ones
that are generic from field to field and
I think coming from biology was very
useful there because there were really
hard conversations in biology in the
late 90s about like you know what are
the criteria for getting a grant
accepted for getting promoted and you
know people were like should we do away
with hypotheses and just like have
grants where you just collect data and
then figure out what what happened just
do away with the scientific method I
mean these and it was intimately
connected with money so people you know
it wasn't like an academic question
people were really interested in these
things I think the challenges are
maintaining communication all the way
from the engineer to the deciders so you
need to make sure that you're doing
something something I say to my group
all the time is don't work on something
that you couldn't explain to the CEO why
you're doing it I don't want to have us
being like doing you know sort of
research projects just for research I've
always wanted to find projects where it
would be clear to anybody in the company
why that's a valuable problem Jared
Lander and it may be here so I gave a
talk about a year ago somebody asked me
like your fresh data scientists at a new
company how do you decide what to do and
I said well what I did was I showed up I
studied the org chart figured out who
were the deciders I figured out what
they feared and then I built a model
that predicted that so I think part of
the challenges are just making sure that
you're doing things that are relevant to
things that people actually care about
and the solution to that is just being a
good listener right you just that's why
people say that a big skill of being a
data scientist is being a good
communicator one of one of the half of
communicating is like really listening
to what
people actually want make sure you build
something people want as they say right
it's great thank you
okay we're we're out of time so if you
want to chat with Chris further he's
gonna be in the back actually on the
right here stage right on in the hunter
room if you want to try with Chris next
up here we have Rafe Colburn from Etsy
on this floor and if you're interested
more in hearing about how data science
is changing publishing that's upstairs
hi Harlan is here who is the former
chief scientist at BuzzFeed and a
colleague or a student I believe of
Chris so Kai Harlan is going to be on
the seventh floor talking about data
science and publishing so you have about
five minutes to sort of run around and
thanks thanks thanks Chris